[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein tolles rezept
für den ramadan aber natürlich können
wir das rezept auch jederzeit zu
bereiten
dann wisst ihr was ich habe den namen
vom rezept vergessen kannst du mir das
sagen das war so ein ganz komischer was
sie reden warum ich habe noch nie gehört
meine mutter hat mir davon erzählt hatte
ich kurz 77 oder simon warte ich muss
kurz gucken sie jedenfalls so lecker aus
was ich mir gedacht habe das mache ich
jetzt für euch also ich meine ich weiß
jetzt was es ist und zwar ist es sind
gericht das blatt wird gerollt und dann
zu kleinen röhrchen geschnitten
aufgestellt im ofen gebacken mit einer
joghurt soße übergossen und dann kommt
auch noch eine hak waschwasser darauf
ziemlich lecker und ich starte jetzt
direkt mit dem yoga und den mache ich
heute selber ihr dürft aber auch gerne
fertigen user verwenden die sind bereits
ausgerollt und vorgebacken ich zeige
euch aber wenig machen und das hier sind
die zutaten ich brauche nur mit salz und
wasser
ich habe jetzt ihr warmes wasser wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch vollkornmehl
nehmen oder beziehungsweise halb und
halb mission
normalerweise kennt man den teig einfach
mit der hand aber ich habe es noch so
viel zu tun deswegen machen wir das
jetzt in der küchenmaschine wasser rein
also viel zu tun heißt für das gericht
möchte ich noch viel tun denn ich will
auch das hackfleisch darüber machen dann
kommt das meer ein
erst mal nur ein teil ich nehme ich das
schön mal durch
und ihr seht ich entdecke auch immer
ganz viele neue türkische gerichte
das heißt wenn ihr mal ein richtig
tolles rezept habe egal ob aus der
türkei oder woanders her
dann schickt mir gerne oder schreibt mir
einfach den namen ich recherchiere bahn
und probierst für euch aus assistieren
habe ich selbst noch nie gegessen aber
ich denke es schmeckt bestimmt ziemlich
gut
so sieht der teig jetzt gut aus er klebt
jetzt auch nicht mehr
also einfach schön lang geschnitten und
jetzt freue mich ihnen zu einer kugel
und lassen dann abgedeckt für 30 minuten
ruhen damit er gleich beim ausrollen ein
bisschen geschmeidiger ist in der
zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon mein
hackfleisch vorbereiten ihr könnt
entweder hackfleisch kaufen vom rind ihr
könnt auch rind und lamm mischen oder
machte tag fleisch einfach selber und
das mache ich jetzt eben schneide jetzt
aus dem fleisch einfach große lange
stücke zu recht und wenn sie dann eben
durch den fleischwolf durchgeben und das
fett schneide ich jetzt nicht weg
sondern nur die szene damit einfach
nicht zu trocken wird und so kann ich
immer selbst bestimmen wie vielfältig im
fleisch habe wenn ich das fleischstück
ich nehme deswegen mal das hackfleisch
auch nichts mit seinem
[Musik]
das kann man die fly streifen einfach
hier oben rein geben und die schnecke im
fleischwolf zieht es fleisch dann hinein
und da kommt sicher vorne durchaus
logisch
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt den teig den ausgeruhten
den teile ich jetzt in zwölf portionen 1
machen wir einfach wie bei einem kuchen
dann jeweils zu einer kugel formen
und auf die arbeitsplatte legen mit
bisschen mehr darunter
und von meiner familie aus der türkei
kenne ich das so da macht man dann
einmal eine große portion setzt sich in
den garten so hat das meine terrasse
über gemacht im dorf und im garten hat
sie dann ihr seid also dass es so ein
bisschen eisenblätter über dem feuer
also so eine schale die so gelegt und da
wird dann der jufa drauf ausgebacken ich
habe es natürlich keins aber ich wette
oder noch nicht wir wollen uns auch
einen baum
ich hätte aber gleich im backofen machen
das zeige ich meine mama mal den tipp
gegeben
jetzt mail und dann nehme ich den ersten
der am links in rom durfte etwas wählen
und mit einem aus holz starb ausrollen
ihr könnt auch weniger zeit direkt an
auch vornehmen also denn holz aus
rohstoff und jetzt soweit aufrollen wie
es mit einem ausreise holz also mit
diesem normalen aus stadt möglich ist
und danach nehme ich dann mein opa war
bzw
das ist einfach ein gekürzter besenstiel
holz hierauf nicht mit leichten
bewegungen nach außen streichen und dann
immer mal wieder die richtung wechseln
damit auch schön rund wird und immer
darauf achten dass es nicht
zusammengelebt
ich sammelte jetzt erstmal alle hier der
holzplatte gesundheit und wir wollen
jetzt erstmal alle aus die decke ich
habe ab mit einem sauberen geschirrtuch
damit sie nicht austrocknen
man hat ja immer so eine große stoff
tischdecke vielleicht muss ich mir das
auch mal holen und dann kann man alle
auf einmal abdecken
meine mama hat mir macht es immer
direkten im opfer war aber das ist
komplizierter
[Musik]
jetzt geht es ans auspacken wir gesagt
entweder auf einem touch also auf diesem
metall über dem feuer oder nehmt einfach
einen backofen wassermeister backofen
boden emailliert das heißt ihr könnt es
direkt auf dem backofen boden machen
ansonsten nehmen sie einfach einen blick
hinein last richtig heiß werden pizza
stein geht auch flammkuchen ofen geht
auch und die lüfter brote die müssen wir
wirklich nur ganz kurz von beiden seiten
gebacken werden aber vorsichtig heißt
hier sind eigentlich nur wichtig dass du
nicht knusprig gebacken werden ich meine
knusprig lebe ich sehe aber ich möchte
gleich noch auf rollen daher wirklich
nur so 30 sekunden von jeder seite so
dass da einfach beim aufrollen gleich
nicht mehr kleben und immer gleich
einpacken so wärmen sie sich gegenseitig
und bleiben schön weich
die brote sind jetzt alle gebacken die
sind jetzt hier noch unter dem tuch
jetzt kann ich bereits eine joghurt soße
zubereiten für die joghurt soße verwende
ich 500 gramm naturjoghurt das ist der
sahne joghurt mit zehn prozent fett 2
knoblauchzehen 300 gramm wasser etwas
chiliflocken salz und pfeffer und dann
für die füllung noch etwas tun um käse
jetzt ruhig den joghurt creme ich dann
füge ich noch das wasser dazu damit der
flüssiger wird die flüssigkeit brauche
ich nämlich gleich für die brote damit
die dann schön durchgegart werden können
im backofen
jetzt kommt hier noch salz rein
jetzt ist es im prinzip über ein joghurt
beträgt sehr lecker übrigens dann noch
etwas pfeffer chiliflocken und den
knoblauch dazugeben
das sind jetzt zwei große 10 ich glaube
ich nicht nur eine große und die sind
nämlich auch sie zwei ist der joghurt
soße schon fertig
jetzt geht's los ich habe das ursprungs
rezept ein bisschen abgewandelt ich
meine es macht sowieso immer jeder bei
den rezepten immer was anderes vor allem
in der türkei von region zu region ist
es unterschiedlich
normalerweise wird so gemacht die ewv
kompletter werden aufgerollt
zugeschnitten und ins blech gesetzt und
gebacken
so ist es mir aber zu trocken also werde
ich jetzt diese yoko zu nehmen und schon
mal die aufgabe damit bestreichen
so kriege ich natürlich auch schon mal
den geschmack rein also richtig gut
vielleicht kam da einfach noch keiner
auf die idee war direkt gesprochen hat
ein problem
wir probieren es einfach
ich bestreite jetzt im laster kurz legen
so werden so schön weich
ich meine man kann sie natürlich auch
rufe arbeiten aber da hat man einfach
die gefahr dass wird einfach zu klebrig
alles also rohr trägt er steht zum einen
nicht gut und zum anderen wird es so
eine richtig klebrige masse
deswegen müssen die schon vor gebacken
werden das war der grund dafür
und ich gebe es hier für den geschmack
noch etwas tun käsereien das ist nomaden
käse richtig lecker würzig einfach so
ein esslöffel voll etwa prof so ein
bisschen rein brösel dann auf rollen
ich weiß jetzt kurz alle an der seite
liegen und rolle jetzt erstmal die
restlichen noch aus
das habe ich hier meine auflaufform dann
nehme ich jetzt einfach ein blech ich
habe hier butter drin kann es einfach
auf den herd stellen und kurz erwärmen
damit die butter schmelzen
so schnell geht das man kann ich damit
hier übernehmen und ich werde jetzt die
e type streifen 5 cm breit schneiden
denn mein immer bleches 6 cm hoch und
dann bleibt noch um zentimeter grund hat
das ist glaube ich ganz gut
[Musik]
dann einfach nebeneinander einstellen
ich habe die backform noch mal geändert
habe eine kleinere genommen jetzt passt
perfekt rein
so wird es jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober unterhitze
erst einmal vorgebacken für 20 minuten
und danach kommt nochmal die restliche
joghurt soße drauf damit einfach schön
weich wird also erst knusprig backen für
die röstaromen und dann noch mal weich
machen
in der zwischenzeit kann ich mich schon
mal am tag fleisch kümmern und zeigt
euch welche zutaten nicht außerdem noch
benötige
[Musik]
für die hackfleisch füllung verwende ich
500 gramm hackfleisch vom rind 20 gramm
butter eine zwiebel etwas salz und
pfeffer jetzt erhebt sich hier die
butter und startet dann das hackfleisch
krümelig an
danach kommen dann die zwiebeln dazu und
werden vier bis fünf minuten mit
angebrachten dann nur noch mit salz und
pfeffer würzen und fertig
[Musik]
jetzt sieht es gut aus und es riecht
schon richtig lecker kommt hätte
joghurts darüber
ich gehe jetzt auch noch direkt die
hackfleisch massa drauf und dass es dann
noch kurz weiter gehen und dann können
wir gleich servieren
normalerweise geht man die soße immer
komplett bis zum rand so werden auch die
äußeren richtig schön weich ich habs
jetzt nicht gemacht
wegen der optik dass ich gleich ein
tolles foto hinbekomme das mache jetzt
einfach noch mal die dampf stufe an
so kommt auch noch feuchtigkeit rein
ansonsten wie gesagt komplett einmal
darüber gießen
so fertig wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr
übrigens nach dem backen das ganze
nochmal meteo kurz servieren und ich
habe hier oben drauf noch eine paprika
soße dafür schmilzt man die mutter fügt
etwas paprikapulver dazu edelsüß kurz
aufkochen lassen und dann drüber geben
moratorium daniel ihre theorien
es hat noch ein bisschen heiß ich habe
es noch mal kurz in den bus wartet der
name wieder vergessen
sion heisst sie runter ist kann ab
verklungen war und ich kenn sie rund als
bereich markt ist eine türkische reißen
hast du schon mal natürlich gegessen so
jährlich jetzt kommt das kind mehr ist
raus paprika butter sowie kuchen echt
hautnah ja das sieht echt aus
ich habe auch nicht so viel chili drin
also hatte sie liegen aber ja genau so
ein bisschen
sagte dass jetzt nur weil ich dir gesagt
habe sozusagen natürlich super ich merke
dass er schreibt so eine warme joghurt
soße und zieht dann von unten schön ins
gepäck nicht mehr lügen müssen draußen
sind sie knuspriger weil ich aus nur
wenig so sahad wenn ihr wenn ihr
vielleicht aus der schwarzmeerregion
kommt wie eine eltern zum beispiel ob
das essen schmeckt bietet für euch wenn
ihr jetzt erkennt wieder schreibt
kommentare auf jeden fall oder schmeckt
lecker was gut aus und muss gleich ist
es auch kultur ist ihr zu hart oder
sprecherrates to school
falls ihr das rezept ausprobieren wollen
ich finde top sechs - blog.de
man kann es eben auch super gut
vorbereiten das haben sich ja meine
zuschauer gefunden gewünscht kann zur
ramadan zeit ihr könnt vorbereiten in
die offene form legen und dann im
prinzip abends kurz vor dem iftar vor
dem fastenbrechen einfach nur noch
backen und fertig aber gut und wenn die
lüfterblätter kauft dann geht es
natürlich einfacher aber erst jetzt
selbst gemacht ist auch super einfach um
und schmeckt vor allem sehr gut viel
spaß beim nachmachen einen schönen
ramadan noch und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss kommt öfter vorbei zum probieren
ja ich bin eine maschine zwei herrliche
maschine der spruch so wie immer so ist
das verschafft mir auch sehr schön
langsam sagte noyer sieht man dass es
gerade essen note justiz ihr chirurg
einem anschlag haben aber am esstisch
[Musik]